this is the hardest one we've ever done
and i think i'm gonna pee my pants
hey guys it's katie and we are back with
another translation challenge or as i
like to call it let's torture jasmine if
you are just joining us we take a recipe
we put it into google translate and we
go from portuguese to latin to hebrew to
cantonese and many many many more and
then we bring it back to english to give
us a hilariously translated recipe
today's recipe actually comes from a
very special guest let's see who it is
hi i'm arya and today i've picked a very
special dish for jasmine to make it's
one that i ate a lot growing up as a kid
so i'm excited to see her take on it i
can't tell you guys exactly what it is
just yet but i'll pop it at the end with
my version of the dish and we'll compare
and see how she did she doesn't even
know it's me coming and so it should be
a real fun treat of a time good luck
good luck indeed let's go give this
recipe to jasmine all right jasmine are
you ready i'm ready this one came from a
special guest
i'm not telling you okay ready yeah you
ready yeah
salt water pisces i do love me a good
pie and you know i am one you ready i'm
ready let's do it saltwater pisces
what's the symbol for pisces it's a fish
fish yes no it's not a clue fish step
number one in between pour one and a
half raw bread in warm water
leave until the fruit bears fruit i
think it's getting crazy now that these
translations
are slowly forming a new grammar rule in
my head like this made sense to you well
no but yeah in between in in in a hole
in a bowl bowls
raw bread i think is flour all right
what kind panko coconut's flour don't
look like kelly she gives it away with
her stop more coating with your eyes
all right i'm going with
all-purpose flour can never go wrong
with all-purpose flour oh the bowls are
here
let's do one and a half cups of flour
i'm just gonna slowly add in water until
a dough forms leave until the fruit
bears fruit i'm gonna cover it and let
it uh rise
there it is
i'm scared
okay i have a solid dough i'm going to
cover it with a towel and let it rise
step number two add three tablespoons of
butter
addition subtraction okay butter butter
butter butter butter butter butter we
have butter are we making a pie crust
does that look like a pie crust no
grapeseed oil avocado oil extra virgin
olive oil let's go with grape seed oil
i'm doing it
well then we will go with three
tablespoons of grape seed oil i will
mixy mixy addition all right i don't
know if this is right in fact i think
it's kind of a dry dough step number
three in a garbage can combine two cups
green bread and one and a half teaspoon
salt stir east dow stir der east dao
stir let's see what are options there's
so much greenery here we got lettuce
green onion and leek i think leek if it
doesn't say how to cut it green bread is
going to be leeks i'm having them
lengthwise and then i'm going to
thinly slice can i have a hint please
you know what katie i'll get a hint from
you are leaks on the right track
sometimes words just appear
no
words just appear yes
i think your hint told me that the leaks
are not correct well dang it so bread
flour in another bowl in a separate bowl
all right we're just gonna go ap flour
one and a half teaspoon salt is it
actually salt though i trust it one two
three der east dow stir
maybe that is whisk together
this looks lovely next step add the
flour to the pan and fall to his on
knees never again
oh
add this flower to the dough and knead
[Music]
i'm so scared i'm trying to figure out
what culture this is
what cuisine does this food come from
also i just feel like i might have
messed up your face right now
next step letting it happen in olive oil
that's how i feel i just said i'm just
gonna let it happen olive oil
no
i was going to use that earlier and then
i used grapeseed oil
now i'm going to add breadcrumbs and
plastic dig one hour i am going to
put it in a plastic
i'm not going to put it okay so i think
add bread crumbs means add my dough to
the bowl and plastic and cover and i'm
going to let it
rest for one hour
i'm a little scared but we'll be okay
it's okay everything's fine learn three
pounds of onions that's a lot of onions
pounds probably is not right
this is really heavy that's not three
pounds for sure cups
cups i don't know in what way i should
cut the onions like should i cut them
into little cubes or should i cut them
into little squares or very thin slices
or mints
hoomp's nose
so i'm going to go
with three
cups of thinly sliced onions
brb
i have my thinly sliced onions here i'm
gonna use three cups of these
next step melt two spoon beds paradise
and two tablespoons of olive oil there
is a large pot on a hot plate
hot plate i need a large pot okay
here's a large pot melt two spoon beds
tablespoons butter makes me feel like
it's paradise i will say two tablespoons
paradise and two tablespoons of olive
oil all right so i am going to kind of
just stick to the recipe for this one i
think butter is paradise so we'll do two
tablespoons of butter and two
tablespoons of olive oil in my large pot
on this hot plate add the laughter
to anchor one and a half teaspoon this
time with a lot of salt for some reason
i'm thinking sugar because it's so sweet
and happy anchor what is anchor olives
you are on a boat and you drop the
anchor and you go fishing two cans of
fish i think i need a hint am i on the
right track with fish being anchor
yes
so i have solid white albacore tuna wild
sardines and anchovies i i pick
anchovies add the laughter
onions
add the laughter to anchor one and a
half teaspoon this time with a lot of
salt ah yes yes yes this time with a lot
of salt step number nine usually the
aroma is yellow when sugar cane until it
is weak
i am just gonna cook these until they're
weak and soft oh sugar cane
i don't have the tools to use this
correctly so no more sugar cane i am
just cooking these onions over medium
high heat until they are soft it's been
like seven days and my onions are
finally nice and weak and soft so let's
move on to the next step step number 10
fry a large sheet of salad dry
fry cook a large sheet fry a large sheet
prepare a large sheet of greens i'm
scared but i think i need to use my
final hints what do you use to fry
oil
oh my gosh
do i have to grease the pan i just
greased my baking sheet i regret using
that hint so no salad
after adjusting the width and height of
the powder make sure to control it with
your fingers oh my dough
my child is this like an onion bread
control it with your fingers huh i'm
just spreading it with my fingers after
adjusting the whole thing maybe it feels
like i'm making pizza or a bread of some
sort flatbread perhaps how thin do we
want this oh my gosh my biceps are
throbbing it's like an 80s workout it is
next step opaque
and walk for 30 minutes walk 30 minutes
it's already been resting bake
i'm going to bake this for 30 minutes
there's no temperature so maybe i'm not
baking it for 30 minutes my heart says
bake it 30 minutes at opaid 350 i don't
know 8 minutes 12 minutes 30 minutes
at 3
50.
all right
and you go
my
this is out of the oven let's move on to
the next step how do you feel about that
katie every time you ask me how i feel
about things i have zero clue
i don't know
rinse the oven 400
[Music]
so what do you think the first line
before that now meant
let it sit for 30 minutes so now that
i've read the next step i assume rinse
the oven means preheat the oven to 400
and i was supposed to let this rest
undo
next step sprinkle caramel sugar on top
of the flour caramelized onions i'm just
so i'm like thinking about how wrong i
am and i'm so sad well this is what you
guys want for me to mess up i'm just
spreading it on here now i'm trying to
just make it tasty we should audition
new oh yeses we should give me your best
oh yes
oh
yes
oh yes
hey baby
step 15 add opinion in x format
add olives and
one and a half teaspoons of tea
add opinion opinion opinion what is this
more olives i almost want to skip this
step i'm so confused i think it's onion
bread of some sort but even then with
olives
my ex format my heart says cocktail
onions
i think opinion is cocktail
onions do you want to try one before you
come into this
i am artfully placing my cocktail onions
in an x format i'm really hoping that
once this video goes up i'm not
embarrassed of this decision
this is beautiful i've now been
initiated into x-men add one and a half
teaspoons of tea
tea
tea time
time
i think one and a half teaspoons of tea
is probably time
a little bit you know um i'm just
thinking about how untasty this looks i
just i don't think olives are olives so
i'm gonna add anchovies yeah i'm gonna
decorate it with anchovies next step add
20 minutes yellow salt is in the ear
oh
bake it for 20 minutes so i'm just going
to skip that step because i already
baked it so then these are supposed to
be cooked a little huh hmm i i i will
just i'll just leave it like this last
step hold on where where did i go wrong
rest
enjoy
now we shall enjoy this is the saltwater
pisces it is
something i don't know where i went
wrong i don't even know where i went
right but i'm excited to see who the
guest is and what the original dish is
let's find out knock knock knock oh my
god is it arya oh my god what did you
make hello
we haven't seen each other in two years
i can't believe you're here i will thank
you for having me and what did you bring
i mean it looks good looks it's it's
something so this is a pizza ladies
french dish from the south of france
from provence so when you take a i hope
when i take a bite of yours i'm gonna
feel like i'm on the french riviera you
will i mean it looks pretty different
but i say we give them a try let's try
this one first bon appetit
wow
very good okay let's try salt water
pisces you also think it's cutting
better well it's because it's made
incorrectly
oh
pickled onion aside it doesn't taste
that bad in the beginning
it was yeast and you did flour it was
supposed to be yeast in warm water
it's not that bad it's it's it's you
know i wouldn't give it to a frenchman
actually i don't mind the
caramelized onions with the pickled
onions at all that's like
really yummy
you like the whole thing the bread is
terrible all right arya thank you so
much for teaching me how to make
saltwater pisces it came out a little
bit different but keep sending katie
recipes at old ladykatie on instagram
and we'll see you guys next time bye
oh yeah oh
yes oh yeah hey baby what
[Music]
you